if you watched the Donald Trump's impeachment
trial date, Bree yesterday on Fox news, you
might not have heard much about this because
they ran a lot of the proceedings on mute
running my pillow commercials over the impeachment
proceedings, or you had hosts talking over
the proceedings talking about how Hunter Biden
is really what this impeachment trial should
be about. But that did not stop Donald Trump
from absolutely losing his mind and tweeting
a record for him 141 times in one day. That
was only up until 6:00 PM and then it continued.
I've told you before, when Donald Trump seemingly
spends the entire day doing nothing but tweeting
sometimes dozens of tweets once I think he
got into the eighties or nineties, we didn't
see that much Twitter activity from Donald
Trump on Tuesday, but I'm now realizing that
was because he was still at the world economic
forum in Davos, Switzerland, and then traveling
back eventually yesterday he had more time
back in Washington, D C and I think sitting
on air force one, and he broke his own personal
record for tweets and retweets in a single
day, tweeting 141 times by 6:00 PM Eastern.
Continuing into the night. And this morning,
most of the tweets are either tweets or retweets
of extremist Republican quotes, videos and
statements, sometimes just absolute nonsense
conspiracy theories from Donald Trump. The
tweets include Trump's and his friends attacks
on the house. Impeachment managers who sort
of are the prosecutors in the impeachment
trial, including of course, a favorite target
of Trump's is extreme anger. Uh, at Adam Schiff
Trump this morning, including a mostly capitalized
tirade. Of course, a hallmark of Trump, his
tweets, both Trump and his supporters are
when you get set up to tweet, you turn caps
lock on and you turn spellcheck off. That's
how if you're getting yourself set up to tweet,
Trump is stuff. You've got a disabled spell,
spellcheck and enable caps lock this morning,
Donald Trump's saying attorney generals all,
I mean, it's attorneys general. I know that
Trump doesn't. Attorney generals from 21 States
are urging the Senate to reject Capitol.
I impeachment. They say the articles have
legal and factual problems and the Democrats
case sets a dangerous historical precedent,
missing an apostrophe, random capitalization.
And then now caps lock engaged buckle in folks,
all caps, even an unsuccessful effort to impeach
the president undermines the integrity of
the 2020 election. Beak says it weaponizes
a process that should only be initiated in
exceedingly rare circumstances and should
never be used for partisan purposes. The Democrats
are trying hard to damage Republicans prior
to the Capitol II election. Uh, I'm, I'm sweating
now. Here's what you need to understand. 141
tweets by 6:00 PM if he started at midnight,
that's 18 hours. Okay. 141 tweets in 18 hours
is eight tweets per hour. That's one tweet
every seven and a half minutes. But that's
if he's not sleeping at all and just tweeting
for 18 hours straight. If we assume that Trump
tweeted 141 times starting at, you know, 5:00
AM maybe, which sounds insane to you or I,
but, but the, you know, um, to you or me,
uh, between 5:00 AM and 6:00 PM 141 tweets,
that's 11 tweets per hour, meaning a tweet
every five and a half minutes.
It's the president of the United States. He's
sending out a tweet or retweet every five
minutes for an entire work day. This amount
of tweeting isn't normal for anyone. If I
look at my Twitter feed and I see someone
at messaged me five times in an hour, I immediately
mute them. I don't have time for this nonsense.
Trump is tweeting 141 times in a day. And
it's funny in a way to see him so triggered
on Twitter. It is funny to see Donald Trump
at these world events like Davos as the guy,
none of the other world leaders really want
to talk to. The idea of the adults are meeting
about important things and Trump is on his
phone tweeting. That's a hilarious image,
but it's really bad. It's an embarrassment.
It's a laughing stock for the United States.
I don't even have time to read 141 tweets
in a day, and Donald Trump is sending out
141 tweets and retweets.
I expect that this is going to get even worse
once the Republicans take over their defense
of Donald Trump in the Senate. And the reason
why is that a lot of Donald Trump, uh, Donald
Trump's Twitter activity is retweeting videos
that are people saying nice things about him
or defending him once his lawyers, uh, Pat
Sippel, Oni and Jay Sekulow, once they take
over, I think Donald Trump could potentially
even break his own record
of 141 tweets
and retweets in
a single day.